SEASON ON TYSON.
>> TELKA.
THAT HAPPENED IN A HURRY.
HE GOT IT UP IN A YEAR.on: THISM
TALKING ABOUT.
THIS CAN HAPPEN.
IT WAS FOOTKOV IS OUT. OF HIS LE
GAMES A LOONEUP HERE FOR THE CO,
LET'S SEE IF HE CT TO THE NET VA
THE BIG SAVE.
AND A SCORES.
JESPER FAST AND IT'S 2-0 THIS ML
TAKE IT AND BURY IT. KOCHETKOV E
OVER FROM THE
AND THEY SCORE.
I BELIEVE THAT'SS ALL.
MAYBE STRUGGLES TO S S CUPS.
>> Matt: HATE ON TO THEEATH IT.
AND GETS A REAL GOOD
CK RICHIE.
COYOTES ARE ON THE ONE.
LOOK AT THE HANDS OF SMI SHOT AE
SLIDE AGO CROSS TO MAKE THE
SAVE.
>> Tyson: IS THAT THE SEQUENCE,
BOYD THOUGHT HE HAD ONE, RAANTA,
NOPE.
NOT THIS 4- CERTAINLY ONE THAT
VEJMELKA HAS GOT TO STOP.
THREW A SCREEN, I
WIDE.
COYOTES TAKE IT TO THE FRONT ANO
BACK TOO FAR, TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SAVE BY RAANTA WHO HNEATH THE C,
THAT'S THE THOUGH.
CAROLINA.
TROCHECK.
THEY COME CLOSEE.
SAVED A GOAL THERE OFF THE 1-GO,
AHO.
SHORTHANDED, TRYING TO GAME.
>> Tyson: YOU COUL REBOUND, SQUS
LOOSE TO AHO ON FRONT, AHO
STOPPED THAT TIME.
THEY CAN'T GET HIM